c'est un geste qu'alain mottez répète
presque tous les jours depuis 26 ans
d'ailleurs la fin de la mêlée cet
artisan est installé à magny les hameaux
depuis 1992 baguette croissant et
pâtisseries dans cette boulangerie tout
est fait maison pour l'amour d'un métier
débuté à l'âge de treize ans et qu'il
est difficile de quitter même
officiellement retraité je me suis
toujours dit que si je m'arrêtais du
jour au lendemain comme ça ça ferait ça
pouvait être dangereux
donc maintenant je suis un peu plus au
contact de la clientèle les ressorties
j'ai directement bombe avait fait pas
grave au qui viennent se servir des
critiques pour durer mais surtout
toujours resté dans l'ombre
même quand il s'agit d'être récompensée
pour son travail alain mottez doit
forcer un naturel timide et plutôt gêné
[Applaudissements]
ce soir la remise officielle de
médailles à l'hôtel de ville de
versailles par la chambre de métiers et
de l'artisanat comme à lamotte et une
cinquantaine de chefs d'entreprise sont
décorés pour leur savoir faire
ce sont des gens qui pour beaucoup sont
relativement réservés maîtrise des
savoirs ancestraux et sont tellement
impliqué dans leur entreprise qu'ils ont
du mal à en parler
cette cérémonie c'est aussi l'occasion
de les mettre à l'honneur de les mettre
au devant de la scène l'artisanat
premier employeur de france chaque année
plus de cent cinquante mille entreprises
sont créées dans le secteur beaucoup
moins en revanche dur comme la
boulangerie mottez plus de 25 ans